foreign
these are actually just toilet plungers
Joanna Fang bully artist for PlayStation
Studios and a master at sonically
translating our world through works like
God of War Ragnarok
Let's uh step into my office
Swatch your step
I love my office this is my creative
space this is the Sony PlayStation Foley
Studio we have tons of really cool stuff
we have like smash iPhones so you know
if we need to like throw something
behind her shoulders it sounds accurate
to what an iPhone sounds like
we have all sorts of weird props and
things of that nature they're just
saying and Foley that is never trust a
clean Foley stage my whole life I've
been trained as a classical musician I'm
kind of always passively listening to
things and passively recording in a
weird way
if I were to sum up all the times when
body reacts like oh that could be a full
year oh that's a cool prop I think I'm
thinking about Foley 13 hours a day to
focus on all these other characters and
literally to walk in their footsteps to
walk in their shoes everything else
melts away like you don't exist anymore
if you take this Indian para knife and
you pair it up with a torque wrench you
get the sound of like an assault rifle
you know you just kind of like shake it
using lump charcoal for snow it's got
like all the cracking characters of ice
pistol holster add manicotti shells to
it you can get a really comprehensive
bone break
gory visceral sounds
we have to do our best divorce where
these props are from and where we could
take them like I can imagine this
sitting on the back of a horse
fully at its best is changing a scene
with sound
not bad today
what we'll do is we'll sometimes take
this and pair it against the wood right
here so if we have these dramatic doors
that have like creaks on them
I always say that the best props it was
to play like a Stradivarius like they
just sing it's like weaponized ASMR you
know what I mean like we're trying to
get the audience to feel something these
textures can completely change how we
view a scene so we gave Joanna a clip
she had never seen before and asked her
to fully it as an action movie and as a
romantic comedy
so in the clip there's a certain Cadence
going on with her Footsteps in terms of
textures I obviously see that she's got
a leather jacket what appears to be two
baguettes underneath her arms just
judging by the way her legs are spiking
I'm going to go ahead and say that she's
probably wearing heels let me
reinterpret this scene as if it were
like a romantic comedy
her leather jacket if it were a rom-com
probably wouldn't Creak that much it's
just you know regular leather jacket
we'll do the baguette first as if just
normal baguette right so
if this is a rom-com posse standard
issue Keys maybe like a wallet or
something
like okay let's just let's just be
creative maybe she's an assassin and the
baguettes are actually cover we have
these heels they're a little darker
let's grid up the floor too you know
just a little bit because heels kind of
over accentuate Grit
[Applause]
cool so these are now the same exact
clip visually but sonically we've
adjusted the fully to accommodate for
two different types of genres
[Music]
everyone wears leather in games so we
have four or five different leather
jackets if the character is like a
little bit evil maybe a little tense we
want to give that character that Sonic
texture this is our
giant water pit it's actually one of the
first things built into the foundations
of the room it's an incredible feature
and it's not something you see every day
card wars are an amazing prop kind of
gross
but sometimes you're able to get it to
like
you know get like some some funny little
characteristics week so someone's like
sliding down like a glass window we're
just so rigged up to hear like
Joanna's love of fully runs deep and
she's always looking to educate people
on her craft
people tend to misunderstand fully as if
it were purely forensic recording I
think most people will be very surprised
if they were to go to fully stage with
the exact props used on set the exact
setups almost in a pure objective way
recreating the sounds you'll find that
the Foley that comes from that it's
extremely lacking of all the things that
we've come to expect from a game or a
film I remember the most challenging
sound that I had to do it was the
simplest sound effect and it broke me it
was like Whoopi Goldberg was like
sauntering up to a bar it just went to
take eight take nine take ten and it was
just killing me I think the reason why I
was having such a hard time with that
queue was just I didn't feel right in my
body you know I used Foley for so long
as this like perfect art form that
helped me shake off frankly my gender
dysphoria for some freaking reason that
one cue made me hate everything about
myself so not long after that I actually
came out of the closet because I was
like it got to the point where I
couldn't I couldn't do my job anymore
this is my entire array of shoes well
not really it's the third of my shoe
collection dress shoes heavy boots men's
athletic wear the squeakiest pairs of
shoes you've ever heard in your life
I don't even wear them for shoes
sometimes I use them as props this is
like my fun little Arsenal
I remember a friend of mine built these
for me and they're made out of aircraft
aluminum they were tuned for a while
they've had their fair share of use
they resonate in ways that you don't
naturally normally get with real swords
because of their Construction
all of these props and tools can come
together in creating a deep and layered
scene to demonstrate this we've asked
Joanna to recreate a segment of the bar
room fight scene from God of War
Ragnarok one of the concepts in the
scene that I really fell in love with
was setting up and paying off this
bouncer weapons aren't allowed inside
we'll have to check them all right Blake
can you cue me up for this sword off the
back here here we go cool ready
[Music]
could I just get a sweetener of the
blades like zushing a little bit when
after she grabs it
and then a trace here also gets his
weapons
[Applause]
we finally get to the middle of the
scene where all that setup pays off
betrays he's forced off the Second Story
by The Bouncer and the bouncer grabs him
and tries to get him to stop
my favorite sound in bar brawl is the
sound of leather as atreus is struggling
to break the grasp of the bouncer
if a trace doesn't hit that button
enough the character dies and it's game
over we got the strangulation sound of
twisting leather and the Clank of armor
as the bouncer's trying to get him to
hold still we do have actual armor
I'm gonna hit the pillars now
when you smash the button enough mole
near the hammer comes flinging through
the air crushes the guy's skull and we
go straight into picking up Thor and
walking him out after he's got his head
knocked off let's just get that sound of
his body just going like relaxing back
Okay cool so hey it's smash we're gonna
get real real gross real fast with this
one
manicotti shells bone breaks
foreign
this is a ax blank that our friend Jeff
provided the fully stage Blake's gonna
record it and we're gonna reverse and
flip it it's gonna get processed and
added with a bunch of different sounds
and it's gonna make up Thor's hammer
hey uh Blake if you don't mind can we
just play back like everything all
together at once
awesome
on a sequence as complicated as Barbara
we're creating over a thousand assets
easy if you can imagine moments like
these happen throughout the entire game
folding a game takes months and months
and months because of the sheer density
attention to detail and contextual
storytelling that we have to do on the
fully stage Joanna's Mastery of her
crafts is unique and even in the digital
age she feels the role of a fully artist
is still vital to storytelling I can
imagine a future where machine learning
azus and Foley but I do not ever believe
that it will take away the simple and
beautiful performative nature of it I've
often felt like when you watch a film
and there isn't much fully it feels like
you're staring through a window it
doesn't feel like you're actually there
Foley to me is a very powerful
performance art language that connects
the audience with the characters and
gets you to feel what they're going
through